.
Unbelievable - I will live here.
And you are not doing anything.
- Worth visiting.
Null, null, null, null, null.
- Oh my god, I wasn't recording.
Auf unserem Weg nach Hause vom Büro
sehen wir sie bei gutem Wetter
fast jeden Tag.
Wir entschieden uns,
in Hawaii zu leben,
weil es damals
für mich einfacher war,
alles hinter mir zu lassen.
Ihr Schweizer habt 450 Sorten Käse.
In Sambia haben wir zwei.
Einer ist orange und den anderen
mag ich nicht mal anfassen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Fliessende Trommelmusik *
Der Ägypter Wael und die
Schweizerin Corinne haben einander
in einem Touristenort
am Roten Meer kennengelernt.
Er war Notfallmediziner,
sie arbeitete in einem Luxushotel.
Eine Begegnung mit Folgen.
Sie sind seit 22 Jahren verheiratet
und haben zwei Kinder.
Was ist das dort vorne?
- Das ist Tiran Island.
Die Insel Tiran.
Mit den Kindern
gingen wir jeweils ...
Wir holten uns dort unten
so ein kleines Boot,
und dann fuhren wir raus
und schauten uns die Delfine an.
Wahnsinn.
Ich schätze es immer noch.
Jedes Mal, wenn wir herkommen,
sage ich: "Wow, pinch me."
Pinch me.
We are lucky.
- We are, we are.
We're very lucky.
Eine verrückte Liebesgeschichte,
die die beiden von Sharm El Sheikh
nach Chicago
und schliesslich nach Kairo führte.
3.30 Uhr morgens.
Bei Habibs brennt schon Licht.
Wael beginnt sein Fitnessprogramm -
1 1/2 Std., und das fast jeden Tag.
Das ist die einzige Zeit am Tag,
an der ich was machen kann.
Ich brauche den Sport,
um arbeiten zu können -
sonst verliere ich Energie.
Wael ist 55 und Sportmediziner.
Er und seine Frau Corinne
haben eine eigene Praxis in Kairo.
Oh, mamma mia.
Und das so früh.
Es ist cool, dass er
so früh aufsteht und das tut.
Er zieht es wirklich immer durch,
aber ich kriege das nicht hin.
Heute liege ich
relativ gut in der Zeit,
darum gibt es einen leckeren Kaffee.
Mmh.
Nein. Nein.
Erwischt.
Ich dachte,
für eine kleine Pfeife wäre Zeit.
You smoke in the morning.
- A small pipe.
Ich brauche sie nach dem Training.
- Das kannst du nicht machen.
Sie hasst es.
Schatz, es ist 6 Uhr früh.
Corinne und Wael leben allein.
Ihre beiden Kinder
sind zur Ausbildung in der Schweiz.
Das Haus der Habibs
liegt im Süden Kairos,
in einer gated community -
einer bewachten Wohnsiedlung.
Davon gibt es
in der 20-Mio.-Stadt viele.
* Sanfte ägyptische Musik *
Es sind nur wenige Kilometer
zur Praxis,
aber die beiden
nehmen immer ein Taxi.
Am Anfang fuhren wir selbst,
doch es wurde zunehmend
zu einem Kampf.
Momentan herrscht noch kein Verkehr,
aber in 1 Std.
wird es wirklich hart.
Wir wollen entspannt
in der Praxis ankommen.
Seit zehn Jahren leben sie
in der Hauptstadt Ägyptens.
Davor waren sie
vier Jahre lang in den USA.
Wael studierte in Chicago
Chiropraktik.
Ich trage drei Schichten.
Die erste schützt die Brille
vor dem Beschlagen.
Die zweite ist besonders dicht,
und die dritte bewahrt die mittlere
vor Verschmutzung
bei unabsichtlicher Berührung.
Wir sind sehr vorsichtig,
und ich betrachte jeden Patienten
als infiziert.
Die Rollen in der Praxis
sind klar verteilt.
Corinne macht die Organisation,
Wael kümmert sich
um die Patienten.
Ready to tango?
- Schau, er trägt die Einlagen.
Das sieht gut aus.
And he walks good.
Das Konzept der beiden kommt an,
auch wenn ihre Öffnungszeiten
für Ägypten nicht normal sind.
Wir setzten uns das Ziel,
wirklich am frühen Morgen anzufangen
und es durchzuziehen.
Viele sagten uns:
"Das könnt ihr vergessen."
"Keiner kommt so früh am Morgen."
Am Anfang öffneten wir um 8.30 Uhr,
jetzt sind wir bei 7.15 Uhr.
Down and out, up and in.
Als Chiropraktiker behandelt Wael
Patientinnen mit Problemen
am Bewegungsapparat
und an der Wirbelsäule.
Very good.
Let's do it on the other side, too.
So, same thing.
* Knacken *
Als Wael seine Praxis
vor zehn Jahren eröffnete,
war er einer der ersten hier
mit dieser Spezialisierung.
Heute kommen
die Patientinnen und Patienten
aus dem gesamten arabischen Raum.
Bonjour, Madame. Comment allez-vous?
* Ägyptische Musik *
Unser Zuhause ist im Moment Sambia.
Wir schauen, wie wir uns wohlfühlen.
Wir wollen aber sicher auch einmal
in die Schweiz gehen.
Wenn die Familienplanung
im Raum steht,
ist es mir auch wichtig,
dass die Kinder
eine Schweizer Schulbildung haben.
* Eindringliche
afrikanisch wirkende Musik *
Vom Kanton Thurgau nach Sambia -
grösser könnte der Kontrast
fast nicht sein.
Für Myriam ist das Alltag.
Vor gut zwei Jahren hat sie hier
den Sambier Chris kennengelernt -
ihren zukünftigen Ehemann.
Sie wollen demnächst heiraten.
* Leises Gespräch *
Sambia liegt im südlichen Teil
Afrikas. Das Land ist arm.
Mehr als die Hälfte der Menschen
muss mit
weniger als 2 ¤ pro Tag auskommen.
* Er spricht Bemba. *
Weisst du, was das ist? Paprika.
Das ist nicht scharf, oder?
- Paprika ist nicht scharf.
Und was ist das?
- Das ist Chili.
Man kann ihn
mit Eukalyptusblättern mischen.
Oh.
Vor einigen Monaten war Chris
zum ersten Mal in der Schweiz.
Für Myriam ist wichtig,
dass er auch ihre Heimat kennt -
gerade weil die Unterschiede
so gross sind.
* Ein Mann ruft etwas. *
I thought he was mad, but he's not.
- Me too.
Ich nehme meistens Chris
oder sonst jemanden mit,
weil ich mich manchmal
nicht 100%ig wohlfühle,
weil man schnell ...
Weil man halt einfach auffällt
und nichts dagegen tun kann.
Es ist für mich einfacher,
wenn ich jemanden dabeihabe.
Wenn mich jemand anspricht,
der kein Englisch kann,
weiss ich dann wenigstens,
worum's geht.
Ich verstehe Myriam
jetzt viel besser,
weil ich dasselbe
in der Schweiz erlebt habe.
Auch wenn mich die Leute
nicht ansprachen,
spürte ich,
dass sie viele Fragen hatten.
Wir konnten aber nicht
miteinander sprechen.
Das fühlte sich seltsam an.
Nicht nur die Hautfarbe,
auch das Geld
ist im Alltag immer wieder ein Thema.
Als Filmer und Fotograf
verdient Chris genug
für ein gutes Leben in Sambia,
aber als Schweizerin kommt Myriam
aus ganz anderen
finanziellen Verhältnissen.
It's okay, okay.
In der Schweiz lernt man schon von
klein auf, wie man Geld sparen kann.
Hier ist das anders.
Wegen der schlechten
wirtschaftlichen Lage
leben die Menschen
von der Hand in den Mund.
Ich wuchs damit auf,
die Dinge zu schätzen, die ich habe.
Sicher hat Myriam mehr Geld als ich,
aber das
spielt für mich keine Rolle.
Als Mann bin ich in der Lage,
dafür zu sorgen,
dass es immer genug zu essen gibt
und es ihr auch sonst
an nichts fehlen wird.
Ich habe nie stark
auf die Rollenverteilung geachtet.
Als ich mit dem Studium begann,
konnte ich mir vorstellen,
nicht zu Hause und Mami zu sein,
sondern dem Job nachzugehen
und vielleicht
mehr zu verdienen als der Mann.
Darum war das
für mich nicht komisch,
auch bevor ich ihn kennenlernte.
Es ist normal und okay für mich.
Die beiden gehen
mit viel Gelassenheit und Zuversicht
ihrer gemeinsamen Zukunft entgegen.
Ich spreche jeden Tag
von morgens bis abends Englisch.
Und er ist
von meinem Englisch genervt.
Und ich denke: "Hey, Junge ..."
"Wie steht's um dein Deutsch?
Wir leben jetzt in der Schweiz."
Diskussionen
führen wir auch nur auf Englisch.
Ich würde gerne manchmal
auf Schweizerdeutsch wechseln -
wie mir halt
der Schnabel gewachsen ist.
Bei Eveline in Sursee
steht Kofferpacken an - schon wieder.
Sie ist erst vor knapp sechs Monaten
mit ihrer Familie
aus New York in die Schweiz gezogen.
Wir haben hier immer noch Kisten,
die ich in storage hatte.
Eigentlich hatte ich mir
vorgenommen, alles auszupacken -
und jetzt gehen wir schon.
Aber immerhin
habe ich einige Kisten geschafft.
Grund ist ihr Mann Danny.
Danny ist Filmproduzent
und hat nach der Corona-Flaute
endlich wieder
ein neues Projekt auf dem Tisch:
eine Serie für Netflix,
die im Osten der USA gedreht wird.
Als Star konnten wir
Halle Berry verpflichten.
Wir sind noch an anderen dran,
deren Namen ich aber
noch nicht sagen kann.
Zu Hause ist Findley der Star.
Was brauchen wir noch für Findley?
Windeln, Sommerspielzeug -
das könnten wir auch dort besorgen.
Bücher?
- Habe ich eingepackt.
Vielleicht eine Decke?
- Die habe ich auch schon.
Es war die Sorge um ihre Familie,
die Eveline aus dem von Corona
geplagten New York
in die Schweiz zurücktrieb.
We will not start
until this upcoming week.
So I didn't want to
give them this budget.
My goal is to get it below 40
on this next pass.
Als Schauspielerin und Sängerin
ist Eveline
das Leben aus dem Koffer gewohnt,
aber seit Findley auf der Welt ist,
ist alles nicht mehr so einfach.
Ich habe mitzuentscheiden.
Wenn mehrere Projekte anstehen,
entscheiden wir gemeinsam
und schauen, ob es für die Familie
das Richtige ist.
Trotzdem bin ich diejenige,
die mitgeht,
und ich betrete dort
luftleeren Raum.
Ich habe nichts, ich kenne niemanden
und habe keinen Job.
Ich war früher nie auf Reisen,
sondern verreiste immer
wegen des Jobs.
Und jetzt ist alles komplett anders.
Und dass wir uns nicht einnisten
können, finde ich anspruchsvoll.
Dass der Partner
das immer versteht ...
Er ist ja im Job drin und meint:
"Ich mache das seit 40 Jahren,
wo ist das Problem?"
Da muss ich sagen: "Moment,
da brauche ich etwas mehr Empathie."
Und da ist er schon ...
... manchmal etwas
in seiner Welt absorbiert.
Er kann vielleicht
nicht so nachempfinden,
dass es für mich superschwer ist,
schon wieder Tschüss zu sagen.
Etwas in mir ist rastlos.
Ich kann mich
nicht fest niederlassen.
Ich muss immer in Bewegung sein.
Du musst aber auch.
- Ja.
Bisher musstest du das
für den Job tun.
Einmal wurde mir ein fester Job
in einem Büro angeboten -
dasselbe Gehalt,
wahrscheinlich sogar mehr.
Und ich sagte ab.
Es stimmte für mich einfach nicht.
Dieses Mal habe ich aber
auch nicht das Gefühl,
dass wir alles abbrechen.
Die Schweiz
ist für mich dauerhafter.
Ob es immer Sursee sein wird,
weiss ich nicht.
* Fröhliche, entspannte Musik *
Eveline wünscht sich
ein Nest für die Familie
und Danny einen Ort,
an dem er arbeiten kann.
* Türklingel *
(Mann) Hallo.
- Hi.
Tschau.
Und dann ist da noch
Evelines eigene Karriere.
Kurz vor der Abreise
hat sie einen Fotografen gebucht.
Sie braucht neue Bilder,
um die Website aufzufrischen.
I forgot my cable.
Ich wollte auf der Website
etwas Bewegtes, wenn man draufgeht.
Jetzt ist immer noch
das alte Zeug drauf.
Eveline hofft, dass sie in den USA
den einen oder anderen Job
ergattern kann.
Ein Drehtag oder ein Werbedreh
liegt sicher drin.
Oder ein Fotoshooting. Die machen
dort ja auch viel Werbung.
Im Theater ist es sicher
nicht möglich - eher im Drehsegment.
Da kann sich sehr spontan
etwas ergeben.
Bye-bye.
Like your mama you like to be
in front of a camera.
Halle Berry muss warten. Jetzt spielt
Findley bei Danny die Hauptrolle.
What's out there?
Do you want to go outside?
Gut. Action.
Ta-da.
- Genau, jetzt kommt der Wind.
Nutz den Wind etwas mehr aus. Genau.
Die Balance zwischen
Evelines Karriere, Dannys Projekten
und Findleys Bedürfnissen
müssen sie noch finden.
Ich dachte nicht wirklich
an Konsequenzen.
Ich hatte nur Augen für Corinne
und ihren Charakter.
Passen wir zusammen?
Wird es eine Erfolgsgeschichte sein?
Jede Herausforderung
zeigte umso mehr,
dass wir
füreinander geschaffen sind.
* Rhythmische,
arabisch klingende Musik *
Dass Kairo
mal ihr Zuhause sein würde,
hätte sich Corinne nicht träumen
lassen, als sie Wael kennenlernte.
Kairo ist die grösste Stadt
auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent.
Sie ist faszinierend, laut
und chaotisch.
Nach einem langen Tag
in der Arztpraxis
haben Corinne und Wael Feierabend.
Sie führen mich zu einer Bar mit
Blick auf das Wahrzeichen Ägyptens.
Schau mal! It's amazing.
- Sieh dir das an.
Unbelievable.
- Even for you?
Sure, of course.
- Of course.
Die Pyramiden von Gise
sind über 2'500 Jahre alt.
Sie gehören zu den ältesten Bauwerken
der Menschheit.
Wow, das ist ja Wahnsinn!
Interessanterweise glauben viele,
die Pyramiden stünden in der Wüste.
Dabei sind sie mittlerweile
direkt am Stadtrand.
A lot of things here
are built illegally.
Ach, das ist illegal?
- Vieles ist illegal.
Die Stadt wächst daran heran.
- Rundherum, schau, dort.
Gut, in der Richtung ist nichts.
Dort ist alles Wüste.
Aber hier ist alles ...
Warum seid ihr überhaupt
nach Kairo gezogen?
Ich glaube, der Nabel der Welt
liegt am Mittelmeer.
Die Kinder sollten die Wahl haben.
Stell dir vor,
sie haben in Kairo gewohnt,
in den Staaten gelebt
und kennen auch die Schweiz.
Es geht darum, eine umfassende
Persönlichkeit zu formen.
Ehrlich gesagt,
war es auch ein finanzieller Aspekt.
Warum?
- Wir lebten fast vier Jahre dort.
Wir waren blank.
Also pleite?
- Pleite, komplett.
Wir hatten keinen Rappen mehr.
- Weil er die Ausbildung gemacht hat?
Klar. Stell dir mal vor, wir gaben
unser gesamtes Erspartes auf.
Aber dann passierte etwas,
mit dem ihr nicht gerechnet hattet.
Drei Wochen nach eurer Ankunft
kam der Arabische Frühling.
Es gab eine Revolution, und man
wusste nicht, wo das hinführen würde:
Würde es einen Bürgerkrieg
oder eine neue Regierung geben?
Was war das für ein Moment?
Ich hatte in meinem Leben
noch nie so viel Angst.
V.a. in der Nacht. Wir schliefen
nicht mehr, weil wir Panzer hörten.
Wir wohnten neben einer Brücke.
Sie fuhren rauf,
und das klang wahnsinnig.
Wir waren immer angezogen.
Ich trug einige Schmuckstücke,
an denen ich sehr hänge.
Ich hatte meine Tasche neben
dem Bett und meinen Laptop dabei.
Wenn etwas passiert wäre, hätte ich
sie nur nehmen und losrennen müssen.
Auch die Kinder waren angezogen. Wir
schliefen drei Tage lang angezogen.
Das war ein seltsames Gefühl.
Ich fragte mich,
wozu ich bereit wäre,
um meine Familie zu verteidigen.
Really?- Bist du gewillt,
jemanden zu verletzen
oder sogar noch weiter zu gehen?
I remember, you were very disturbed.
Ich merkte,
dass ich kein Problem hätte,
jemanden zu verletzen,
der meiner Familie etwas antun will.
Warum seid ihr trotzdem geblieben?
Warum seid ihr nicht
in die Schweiz zurückgegangen?
Direkt danach verschob sich
die Macht zu den Muslimbrüdern.
Sie waren natürlich nicht
qualifiziert, ein Land zu führen.
A country isn't a grocery store.
Wir wussten,
dass es nicht lange gutgehen würde.
Nichts ist nachhaltig:
Es gab Stromausfälle
und Wassermangel.
Doch die Dinge änderten sich
dramatisch und sehr schnell.
Der Preis dafür war hoch.
Nun haben wir eine Militärregierung,
aber zumindest
konnten wir im Land bleiben.
Politik ist ein heikles Thema.
"Keep a low profile"
ist Corinne und Waels Motto -
"einfach nicht auffallen".
Für Myriam und Chris in Sambia
sind es nur noch wenige Tage
bis zur Hochzeit.
Es wird ein Fest mit allem,
was dazugehört.
Das Hochzeitskleid und den Anzug
haben sie längst gekauft.
Jetzt fehlt nur noch das Styling.
Chris will für den grossen Tag
eine besondere Frisur haben.
(Corinne) Thank you.
* Chris spricht Bemba. *
Hi.
- (Frau) What's your name?
I'm Myriam.
- Myriam.
So. Ich möchte mir
die Haare flechten lassen,
damit ich an der Hochzeit
gut aussehe.
* Langsame Hip-Hop-Melodie *
Chris lässt sich Cornrows flechten.
Dabei werden die Haare
eng an der Kopfhaut geflochten.
Sorry, I need to go.
Auch Myriam hat noch einen Termin.
Sie geht zur Pediküre.
Die Vorfreude auf das Hochzeitsfest
ist bei beiden riesig,
aber Chris weiss auch,
dass die Ehe mit Myriam
nicht immer nur einfach sein wird.
Thank you, ladies.
Es wird Herausforderungen geben.
Wenn ich in die Schweiz ziehe, werde
ich alles verlassen, was ich kenne:
meine Kultur,
die Menschen, das Essen.
Ich werde
etwas komplett Neues beginnen.
Das wäre für jeden schwierig.
Man kommt an einen Punkt, an dem man
bereit ist, Opfer zu bringen.
In der Schweiz wird Myriams Familie
zu meiner Familie werden.
Aber daran werde ich mich gewöhnen.
Natürlich hoffe ich,
dass ich mich völlig
in die Kultur integrieren kann.
So what is this for, actually?
What does it do?
Does it make the skin softer?
Mhm.
- Okay.
In einem Spa hat sich Myriam
mit einer Freundin aus Deutschland
verabredet,
die auch in Sambia arbeitet.
Beide wissen, wie es ist,
die Heimat zu verlassen -
im Gegensatz zu Chris.
Ich habe auch schon mit Afrikanern
in der Schweiz darüber gesprochen,
dass dieses Kommunale einfach fehlt.
Auch wenn wir Schweizer
eine Gemeinschaft haben,
ist das
auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise.
Ich sehe es auch bei mir:
Mal die eigene Sprache
mit jemandem sprechen
oder das Essen essen,
das zu Hause zubereitet wird.
Er sagt jetzt zwar,
dass das für ihn easy sein wird,
aber es wird wahrscheinlich
schon auch schwer für ihn.
(Lachend) Hallo, hallo.
- Hi.
Wie geht es euch?
Wir sind total entspannt.
Schick. Ich bin auch fertig.
* Myriam seufzt zufrieden. *
I do.
Okay. Are you guys ready to roll?
* Antreibende Gitarrenmusik *
Unsere beiden Kulturen
sind unterschiedlich.
Ich würde nicht sagen,
dass sie zueinander passen,
aber die Unterschiede
erweitern unseren Horizont.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmusik *
Bei Fabienne und Francis in Hawaii
sieht das Leben auf den ersten Blick
immer nach Ferien aus.
What do you want to eat?
Do you feel like eating shrimp?
Can I have
a garlic shrimp plate, please?
Der Monteur
mit den philippinischen Wurzeln
und die Glarner Sachbearbeiterin
geniessen ihren freien Tag.
Er mag gerne Fleisch und Fisch.
Wenn es heiss ist,
mag ich lieber Früchte.
Darum ... Ja.
Es gibt im Alltag einige Punkte, in
denen sie nicht einer Meinung sind,
aber diese Unterschiede
bringen einen weiter, finden sie.
Ich habe aufgehört,
Konserven zu kaufen.
Mit Essen aus der Dose
bin ich aufgewachsen,
weil es günstiger
und einfach zuzubereiten war.
Fabienne hat mich überzeugt,
dass das ungesund ist.
Das ist eins der Dinge, die ich in
meinem Leben für sie geändert habe.
Aber Spam esse ich immer noch.
Dosenfleisch ist köstlich.
Auch Fabienne
hat von Francis gelernt.
Ich hatte anfangs grosse Mühe.
Wenn wir irgendwo hingingen,
waren wir immer zu spät dran.
Ich als Schweizerin
bin gerne pünktlich.
Wenn es mir wichtig war,
sagte ich ihm einfach:
"Heute on Swiss time."
Das hat funktioniert.
Anfangs machte es mich
manchmal rasend,
wenn ich bereit war
und noch 1 1/2 Std. warten musste.
Aber das lernt man mit der Zeit.
Es hat keine Eile,
etwas zu erledigen.
Wenn man an den Strand geht,
muss man nicht
zu einer bestimmten Zeit dort sein.
Der Strand wird immer da sein.
So verschieden sie sind,
haben die beiden schnell gemerkt,
dass es wichtig ist, grosszügig
zu sein und Kompromisse einzugehen,
um miteinander glücklich zu werden.
In San Francisco
geht's um eine andere Art Glück,
nämlich um das von Kindern.
Fabiennes Schwester Noëlle
macht sich für die Arbeit fertig.
Ich muss mich verkleiden,
weil wir Fasching feiern.
Wenn wir das
den ganzen Tag machen würden,
würde ich mich
natürlich total schminken.
Ich verkleide mich als kleines Reh.
Noëlle ist Kindergärtnerin
an einer deutschsprachigen Schule.
Sieht man, dass ich ein Reh bin?
We want to talk about,
real quick, what Fasching is.
What does that mean, hm?
Nach acht langen Wochen
in der Schweiz ist Noëlle froh,
dass sie wieder
bei ihrem Freund in den USA ist.
Matt ist Software-Ingenieur.
Die beiden sind
seit bald sieben Jahren ein Paar.
Er tankt Energie,
indem er online Videogames spielt.
Oder er richtet im Haus etwas ein,
was mit Technik zu tun hat.
Und ich fülle meine Energie auf,
indem ich rausgehe, etwas unternehme
und Menschen treffe.
Ich musste lernen,
dass ihm nicht guttut,
was mir guttut - und umgekehrt.
Das musste ich akzeptieren.
This one?
- Yeah. We don't have to bring lots.
Freunde zu treffen,
liegt im Moment nicht drin.
Schuld ist einmal mehr Corona.
Dafür haben die beiden dank
Homeoffice mehr Zeit füreinander.
Silverware?
- It's in the bag. Maybe a knife.
Wir gehen oft picknicken.
Das machen wir gerne.
Er hat mir das letztes Jahr
zu Weihnachten geschenkt:
einen Hightech-Picknicktisch.
Es ist süss.
Es ist ein Tisch,
und er hat Halterungen
für Weingläser und Flaschenöffner.
Richtig cool.
Du hast alles
auf Google umgestellt, oder?
Du kannst "Alexa" sagen.
- Alexa.
Schalte die Lichter aus.
It didn't go "da-dam"?
- It did.
* Lockerer Westernrock *
Wupah!
Seit drei Jahren
lebt Noëlle in San Francisco.
Davor führten sie eine Fernbeziehung.
Noëlle zog erst
mit einem Arbeitsvisum um.
Die Unabhängigkeit ist ihr wichtig.
* Klirren *
Ich hatte mich so
auf den Wein gefreut.
No wine for us.
Ich bin irgendwo angestossen.
Sie fiel einfach raus.
Ich kann die Tasche nehmen.
Pass auf mit den Scherben.
I don't want you to cut yourself.
- It's okay.
Come on, it's okay.
Let's go.
Es bringt Glück.
- Ja, ja.
Das mit dem Glück
ist aber so eine Sache.
Der Himmel ist ja total schwarz.
I know.
Sie wären aber nicht Noëlle und Matt,
wenn sie es
nicht trotzdem probieren würden.
Come on.
Yeah, it's already starting.
Sie haben nicht gesagt,
dass es heute regnen würde.
Schau, wie dunkel es dort ist.
Lass uns besser zusammenpacken.
- Yeah.
Another day?- Wir verschieben es
auf nächstes Wochenende.
Momentan haben wir ja viel Zeit.
Und dann nehmen wir
zwei Weinflaschen mit.
Yes. Es hat nicht sein sollen.
Magners wird uns hassen.
What are we doing?
Magners, come.
- Good boy.
* Fröhlicher Westernrock *
Statt eines Picknicks im Park
also eins auf der Luftmatratze.
Improvisieren
sind die beiden gewohnt.
Sie mussten
schon einige Krisen meistern.
Nicht, weil sie sich nicht verstehen,
sondern einfach, weil sie
unterschiedliche Pässe haben.
Wir haben so viel durchgemacht.
Wenn man aus
zwei verschiedenen Ländern kommt ...
Bei uns gab es immer
irgendein Problem.
Einfach, weil er aus den USA kommt
und ich aus der Schweiz.
Es war nie einfach.
Als ich gerade in der Schweiz war,
fragte ich mich:
"Scheisse", sorry, "warum kann es
für uns nicht einfach normal sein?"
Wenn ich einen Schweizer hätte,
stünden wir nicht
vor diesen Problemen.
Aber letztlich hat uns das
wieder mehr verbunden.
Solche Dinge verbinden einfach.
Dann hält man sich auch stärker
daran fest und glaubt mehr daran,
dass es die richtige Liebe ist.
Egal,
was draussen in der Welt passiert,
wir können immer zusammenkommen.
Das löst nicht alle Probleme,
aber gemeinsam können wir zumindest
unsere Batterien wieder aufladen.
Zu Hause finden wir die Liebe,
die wir brauchen.
Och.
Als Arzt hat Wael
nicht viel Freizeit.
Aber wenn es mal passt, streift er
mit seiner Kamera durch Kairo.
Er ist hier aufgewachsen.
Als Sohn einer Koptin
und eines Christen
gehört Wael
in Ägypten zu einer Minderheit.
Als junger Mann
habe er darunter gelitten,
aber heute mache es für ihn
keinen Unterschied mehr.
* Sie sprechen arabisch. *
Es ist ein Land voller Kontraste.
Es gibt das Teure, das Billige,
sehr Schmutziges und Blitzsauberes.
Der Kontrast ist dramatisch,
und das liebe ich.
Corinne wuchs im Kanton Zürich
und im Welschland auf.
1996 zog sie
für die Arbeit nach Ägypten -
zwei Jahre bevor sie
Wael kennenlernte.
Exzellent.
- Bin ich gesund?
28 °C? Ich sollte zum Arzt gehen.
(Lachend) No Corona.
Das ist wirklich
fast wie in der Migros.
Es ist super,
wie im Schlaraffenland.
Etwas Gruyère muss sein.
Wenn man nicht mehr
in der Schweiz ist,
bekommt man plötzlich Heimatgefühle.
Was hat Corinnes Schweizer Kultur
in dein Leben gebracht,
was es ohne sie nicht gäbe?
Corinne ist extrem gut organisiert.
Ohne sie wäre ich verloren -
finanziell, mit den Rechnungen,
den Geburtsurkunden der Kinder ...
Du solltest ihr Ablagesystem sehen.
Damit habe ich nichts zu tun.
Sie kümmert sich um alles.
Ohne sie wäre ich verloren.
Es gibt doch sicher auch Dinge,
bei denen ihr
Kompromisse eingehen musstet.
Es braucht nicht viel.
Wenn es harte Arbeit gewesen wäre,
hätte es nicht funktioniert.
Man fühlt es von Anfang an.
Braucht es grosse Anstrengungen,
wird es nicht klappen.
Ihr seid 22 Jahre verheiratet,
immer noch zusammen
und glücklich, wie es scheint.
We are.
- Wie macht ihr das?
Keiner von uns
beansprucht ein festes Territorium.
Wir teilen uns einen Kontinent.
Alles ist möglich.
Wir können über alles sprechen
und es neu verhandeln.
Und wir erachten nichts
als selbstverständlich.
Man muss sich die Neugier bewahren,
dann läuft es von allein.
Flexibel bleiben -
das würde ich allen raten.
Be flexible?
- Be flexible in life.
Wenn ich eine Beziehung
mit einer Frau beginne,
muss es etwas Ernsthaftes sein,
denn ich will ihre Gefühle
nicht verletzen.
Der Weg war also klar:
Aus der Freundin wird die Verlobte,
und dann kommt die Hochzeit.
Dann lernte ich sie kennen
und wusste: Sie ist es.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmusik *
Auch das ist Sambia:
Natur wie aus dem Bilderbuch.
In dieser Safari-Lodge etwas
ausserhalb der Hauptstadt Lusaka
geben sich Myriam und Chris
morgen das Jawort.
Myriams Geschwister, ihre Freundinnen
und ihre Eltern
sind schon
vor einigen Tagen angereist.
Chris' Trauzeugen
kommen auch gerade an.
Das ist Myriam.
Und das sind
ihre Freundinnen, Julia und Rebecca.
Später wirst du
auch noch die Familie treffen.
This is Ludia.
- Delia.
* Räuspern *
- Okay, we can go.
Ich bin entspannter,
da die Jungs hier sind.
Bisher war ich
nur von Frauen umgeben
und verstand auch die Sprache nicht.
Das war sehr anstrengend.
Du hörst zu,
weisst aber nicht,
wovon sie sprechen.
Jetzt kann ich einfach
Bemba mit ihnen sprechen.
Das freut mich.
* Er spricht Bemba. *
Chris' Familie
kommt erst am Hochzeitstag.
Die Übernachtung in dieser Lodge
wäre schlicht zu teuer.
Mit Wilfried, einem seiner
Trauzeugen, ist Chris aufgewachsen.
Oh, there's a disco ball, man.
- Den benutzen wir für die Party.
Er sollte Myriam immer
wie eine Schweizerin behandeln
und nicht versuchen,
sie in eine Sambierin zu verwandeln.
Das Wichtigste ist aber:
glückliche Frau, entspanntes Leben.
So werden sie es
gut miteinander haben.
(Frau) Awesome.
Aber das muss ziemlich weit hoch.
- Ja, darum glaube ich ...
An die Stange? Ja.
Das Hochzeitskleid
hat Myriam in Sambia gefunden.
Ich hatte keine
besondere Vorstellung davon,
wie es aussehen sollte.
Ich wusste nur: keine Ärmel
und ein Prinzessinnenkleid.
Sehr schön, genau.
Ein grosses.
- Ja.
Dann fand ich das.
Es hatte aber noch Ärmel.
Aber ich konnte es ändern lassen.
Die Zeremonie findet draussen statt.
Mit den Hochzeitsplanern bespricht
Myriam noch einmal den Ablauf.
Sie haben 70 Gäste aus der Schweiz
und Sambia eingeladen.
Hier verläuft der Teppich.
Der Bogen wird vorne sein.
Wie werdet ihr
die Stühle aufstellen?
Wie viele Reihen wird es geben?
Immer fünf pro Reihe.
Five by five, okay.
Am meisten freue ich mich darauf,
beide Welten zu verbinden.
Ich habe meine Schweizer Freunde,
meine Schweizer Familie,
aber ich habe auch hier
Freunde und Familie.
Sie kennen einander z.T. schon,
aber jetzt sehen sich alle mal.
Das ist für mich
ein megaschöner Moment.
So kann ich sagen:
"Wir sind eins, und dazu gehören
quasi auch Familie und Freunde."
* Jubelrufe *
In der nächsten Folge ist der grosse
Tag für Chris und Myriam endlich da.
In Ägypten ist Wael mit
dem dicken Portemonnaie unterwegs.
Corinne und er
bauen sich ein neues Zuhause.
Welches ist eures?
Hier werden wir ein Cheminée haben.
Man kommt rein und sieht das Feuer.
I'm happy she's here with me.
In Boston müssen sich
Eveline und Danny erst zurechtfinden.
Es war eine solche Schicht
verrottetes Laub,
ich musste erst alles putzen.
Das ist "Hin und weg".
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be,
forever you and me. Take my hand.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2021